the new palace is the biggest castle
ever built for King Frederick the Great
yet
it is greatly unknown noir stories tend
to flock to his private residence
sanssouci on the other side of the park
so we decided to take a closer look at
the new palace Frederick the Great had
the Baroque Palace built at the end of
the Seven Years War
construction work took place from 1763
to 1769 and just six and a half years he
sought to demonstrate the power and
glories of Prussia calling the building
and from fava nut which is a synonym for
boastful this was also the goal of this
palace to show that the Prussians were
still a great power the king himself
rarely spent time in the new palace it
was predominantly used to accommodate
his guests
[Music]
the grotto hall is impressive displaying
over 20,000 and crusted shouts and
stones another exceptional feature is a
marble floor it was inspired by the
seabed
[Music]
directly above the grotto hole is this
fantastic marble hole it measures 600
square meters and it is 16 meters high
it is a miracle that it hasn't collapsed
yet as it is free-floating supported
only by wooden beams
that's why visitors like me can just
walk over these glass walkways
[Music]
noble men and women used to dine in the
banquet hall it still has the original
wallpaper which is 250 years old
usually guests in a palace were given
two rooms but the new palace was so big
that everyone was allocated ten rooms to
use and each room is as large as an
average families house
[Music]
this is the back of the new palace this
place was used for events like big
festivals and military ceremonies
when you visit pot stop don't just go to
salsa si make sure that you include the
new palace in your agenda it is very
worth a trip